je suis désolé euh après un déjeuner
exceptionnel mangé dans un nouveau
restaurant j' t'ai invité ah une
personne merci d'ailleurs voilà c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un m'invite ah
bon classe c'est fou sans rigolerère
fois que tu te laisses inviter la
personne a payé ben moi quand je veux
payer tu m'envoie chier oui mais parce
que toi tu tu me fais chier déjà non
mais c'est vrai invité c'est le resto
qui vous inviteé ou la personne la
personne c'est quelqu'un de Rich invité
je je je je je je peux pas le dire mais
plus riche que vous j'étais invité c'est
le geste vous a troué quel c'est le
geste franchement j'étais j'étaé j'étais
touché vous a touché j'étais touché j'ai
dit et la personne m'avait invité j'ai
dis d'accord vas-y et elle m'a elle m'a
invité j'ai pas payé non non c'est bon
un restaurant genre un peu chic chic
base d'étoile ah et du coup quand on
vous a proposé de payer est-ce que vous
avez regretté de pas avoir plus mangé
non parce que non parce que non non non
non non non parce que même la personne
avait choisi pour moi ce que je mangeais
ah ah ouais sair ce que vous avez
frchement class classe classe Personne
savait que je mangeais pas de voilà de
viande tout ça légumes petite omelette
mais genre omelettes TR étoiles tu vois
et le dessert incroyable un livre de
chocolat et la personne m'a dit tu aimes
le chocolat la leureadore laisse-moi
faire un livre de chocolat oh là là
c'est magnifique elle m'a dit regarde tu
vois BIM tu fait tomber le livre et le
chocolat se disperse partout vos deux
passions littérature et chocolat
[Rires]
exactement non mais
vraiment alors voilà et après la pluie
quoi et moi j'adore marcher sous la
pluie ah ouais j'adore j'ai deux
passions dans la vie marcher sous la
pluie manger des livres non mais c'est
liv et j'ai marché sous la pluie
incroyable c'est dingue de marcher sous
la pluie comme ça et et j'adore marcher
sous la pluie et quand la pluie arrive
et il y a j'ai vu j'étais sur les qu
scèes et il y avait des
rats ah quelle horreur donc j'ai
réunissé mes trois passions non mais
sans déconner franchement j'étais
j'étais heureux j'étais heureux de
marcher avec des rats je vous jure que
c'est vrai et les rat me disaient tiens
c'est fou comme on a des similitudes
vous avez tapé la discute bien sûr c'est
V non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est vrai je commence à kiffer les rat
et quelles sont les similitudes alors
ouais bah déjàcher une barre de fer
dire que je suis un rat non non mais
c'est V non non non mais c'est vrai non
non non voilà non mais j'ai kiffé voilà
je vous dis et je me suis posé une
question j'étais sur lesqu SC parce que
je suis rentré à j'ai voulu rentrer à
pied de mon déjeuner de mon déjeuner vot
personnel suit
derrière oui
oui sortez un peu s'il vous
plaît trop tu viens trop tu viens trop
tu viens trop je pense on va remettre un
peu
Bernard
non non mais et et c'est vrai que je me
suis posé une question et que je vais
vous poser ah que je me dit et je
pensais à vous aussi chez vous je me
disais la vie parfois ben on fait on
fait pas grandchose en fait on fait des
trucs tu vois c'est toujours et je me
suis dit qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de plus
fou dans ma vie c'est la personne en
fait avec qui je qui m'avait demandé m'a
posé cette question après j'ai réfléchi
et et et j'ai dit qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait de plus fou dans ma vie et je me
suis dit tiens c'est vrai qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait de plus fou ce soit
peut-être un truc de fou une cascade que
ce soit fait ces trucs par amour ou bien
peut-être un risque que vous avez pris
c'est pas forcément voilà même avec une
avec une fille ou un garçon qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait de plus fou dans
votre vie et vous allez voir que vous
avez tous des vies de merde non mais
c'est ça mais je vous jure que c'est
vrai parce que je vous demande de
réfléchir vous aussi chez vous à
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de plus fou
dans votre vie un truc de ouf ça veut
dire tu vois vraiment tu te dis ah ouais
tu vois j'ai fait un truc de ouf tu vois
et me dites pas j'ai sauté en par ch on
s'en fout c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
de ouf en fait tu vois c'est vrai tu
vois toi ce que tu as fait de fou par
exemple c'est sans rigoler c'est vrai
c'est demander ta meuf ou la main de ta
meuf dans une émission on dir ça c'est
un truc de ouf c'est un truc de oufès tu
as pris un vent tu as pris un vent c'est
pas mais non mais s ça c'est un truc de
ouf ça c'est un truc de ouf tu vois
moi deou moi je fais plein de trucs par
exemple j'ai j'ai fait des cascades j'ai
fait des trucs mais c'est vrai je fais
des cascades sur le s le toit une
voiture j'ai fait j'ai fait d'une suite
libre de de de 30 de 35 m voilà j'ai
fait des trucs
voilàcal déb et je tiens à dire que je
suis top 100 panel et aujourd'hui je
viens de voir 86e en fait je suis
premier dans ma catégorie
d'âge numéro 1
français grce à
vous et ça voilà ça c'est mais c'est pas
un truc de fou ça plus coou les cascades
les trucs tu vois j'ai voilà mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de ouf dans
votre VI moi un jour aussi c'est quand
je suis parti à à 3h du matin euh pour
aller euh je me rappelle ça c'était un
truc de fou je me rappelle même si
arrivé je vous avais déjà raconté
l'histoire c'était rien j'étais persuadé
que j'étais euh j'étais pour chassé par
terroristes et je suis parti à 3h du
matin euh les chercher enfin chercher
les gars à Lille euh à roué voilà ça
céit un truc de fou ça c'est c'est un
restaurant c'est c'est voilà mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de fou de
fou en fait de fou plus fou que par la
quoi fou que par la des fou par la des
ou non mais c'est vrai voyez ou pas et
en fait et en fait quand vous
réfléchissez c'est pour ça vous êtes
obligé de me répondre en fait il a rien
quand vous réfléchissez il y a pas de
truc de fou que vous avez fait pour
passer d'un appart de l'appartement 105
qui était inhabité j'avais une copine
qui habita à l'appartement 108 fallait
faire trois appartements pour aller la
rejoindre et je passais du 9e étage au
bord de la fenêtre je passais trois
appartements qu'on retient retient c'est
que lui il est prê il est prêt à mourir
pour
Ken
voilà c'est voilà c'est dans sabioin
c'est dans saavais 14 ansé pas mal quand
même ça va ça va c'est pas c'est pas
c'est voilà c'est dangereux dangereux ou
c'est mais c'est voilà qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu as fait de fou toi dans
ta vie j'ai avoué à une ex pourant qu'il
m'avait pas chopé que je l'avais trompé
multiples reprises parce que je savais
qu'elle avait une grande propension
pardon donc je vais tout à balancer un
soir comme ça c'est nul ça bah oui
surtout qu'elle m'a
larguéessortessort il est plus en plus
bête j'en peux plus de plus en plus bête
j'en peux plus allez sorte de plus en
plus bête estceil faut que je mon moment
estce que e ça va reste ça va JAAC
cardos tuas pas fait des trucs de fou
toi j'ai changé deux fois de métier déjà
non mais on s'en fout de ça moi aussi
j'ai changé deux fois de
voiture non non mais c'est vrai j'ai
changé deux fois de métier quand même
mais attends mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est nul ça tu trouves ça nul bah
oui c'est quoi c'est quoi quand tu es
danseur classique et que tu as 22 ans et
que tu
appelles ta famille en disant je vais
tout balancer et je vais faire autre
chose ah c'est vrai ouais c'est pas mal
ouais c'est pas mal pas mal je me suis
arrêté du jour au lendemain c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal non non mais non non
c'est bon
non c'est bon c'est bon Gill qu'est-ce
que tu as fait toi bah en dehors du
mariage je pense que le truc le plus fou
que j'ai fait c'est de c'est de me
marier à Cuba ah ouais parce que ça
c'est fou parce qu'il y a eu des
enquêtes administratives très poussées
sur nous deux et après il faut faire
légaliser ça c'est un truc de fou voilà
rencontrer quelqu'un à Cuba se marier à
mari à La Havane c'est pas commun il y a
ma mère qui me dit moi la chose la plus
folle que j'ai faite dans ma vie c'est
devenir ta
mère c'était la meilleure rien dire si
tu veux que je te dise bon tout
je me souviens d'un truc non mais je
peux plus je peux plus euh oui pas non
ah non mais jeuse ah non je suis pas
d'accord attends j'ai un truc truc moi
j'ai volé 2h dem0 à bord du Mirage 2000
et je me suis tenu et je peux vous dire
qu'il m'a pas ménagé c'est un avion
alors ça c'est des trucs de fou quand on
est dans des
trucs F
FM mais attends mais ça va c'est rien ça
arrê un avion de chasse mais oui mais
arrête un avion de chasseour de la table
regarde tout le monde 2h et je me suis
tenue c'est beau ouais c'est ouais mais
ça fait pas ça fait pas vibrer toi c'est
colanta que tuas fait colanta c'est
incroable excuse-moi je parle un gars là
merci je parle à un gars s'il vous plaît
merci ouais non mais toi c'est colanta
c'était colanta en 2003 ouais une belle
aventure et on a bien kiffé on c'est pas
une
interview je te dis c'est pas une
interview alors l'aventure j'en
rien mais non mais frérot c'est ça toi
c'est colanta toi tuas deux trucs
colanta coupé t VE franchement non mais
c'est vrai frement c'tait de Baill
c'était de bailles de ouf Benaï toi tuas
rien fait toi à part faire des macroudes
non
mais faire des macros dans altitude non
mais franchement c'est vrai pour toi
j'ai sauté j'ai sauté en parachute et
pour mon le le le papa de mon mon fils
voyage de voyage de nos on était à à
Tahiti à BoraBora et pour lui faire
plaisir alors que j'avais la la plus
grande peur du monde il a ramené non
j'ai nagé avec des requins j'avais très
très peur moi j'ai nagé alors moi sa
j'avou que c'était vraiment mais les
requins par qu'il y a des gros sa qu'il
y a des petits requins qui sont très
dangereux j'aiit non mais c'est vrai moi
je me rappelle moi j'étais î turquoise
moi j'étais j'ai passé beaucoup sur les
îles turquises turqu cikos et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des requins et et les
requins les petits requins étaient
beaucoup plus dangereux que les les gros
je vous j que c'est vrai parce que
parfois les petits requins nous
entcerclé comme ça il fallait leur
parler g vas-y qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive mais déconn c'est vrai voilà je
vous le dis vous Kelly ça va ben je
réfléchis là depuis tout à l'heure et je
non c'est pas vrai la chose la plus
folle que vous avez fait c'est que vous
étiez derrière oui vous êes passé tu ah
c'est pas mal ah ouii moi j'ai fait le
chemin inverse c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal ouais c'est pas mal lui il a fait le
chemin inverse non non mais c'est pas
mal mais ça veut pas dire que vous avez
une vie de merde pas du tout c'est que
parfois en fait on se rend compte que la
vie faut se lâcher non pas du mais
lâcher ça veut rien dire faut oser faire
des chos faut se lâcher en fait c'est
c'est que vous n'avez pas l'occasion oui
euh de faire des trucs de fou en fait
c'est vrai quelle est l'occasion de
faire des trucs de fou déjà ce que vous
faites tous les soirs
ou c'est av incroable vra dev vous avez
pas une vie la vie de tout le monde ou
pas c'est vrai voilà et ben donc me
faites pas
chier voilà en résumé me faites pas
chier ok c'était pour ça voil tout ça
pour vous dire partez bien